بسم الله ما شاء الله
الان على الهواء
مساء الخيرات على حضراتكم ربنا يسعد
ليلتكم وكل ايامكم ان شاء الله انا
الاسئله كلها
كنت لسه هقول انا في انتظار اسئله حضراتكم
طيب طبعا انا عاوز استاذن
بجيلي رسايل بيقولوا لي ان احنا بنحاول
مره واتنين وتلاته نبعد اسئله
ولا تجاب انا ما عنديش تفسير لانه زي ما
انتم شايفين حضراتكم انا باخد الاسئله
بالترتيب
يعني بيكونوا جاهزين بالاسئله في البدايه
فدائما بتوقف في البدايه استاذنكم انه بس
الاصدقاء اللي هم اسئلتهم لا تجاب يكتب
انه يحاول يكتب السؤال بدري شويه
هحاول اطول شويه خصوصا احنا باقينا نتقابل
كل اسبوع فاتمنى يا رب ان هذه المره
والمرات المقبله ما يكونش فيه سؤال كرر
ولم اتمكن من الاجابه عليه طبعا ده لو انا
عارف الاجابه يعني اول سؤال من اخونا يوسف
صديق
ماذا لو كان اليهود اختاروا موطن كان ان
تقوم اصلا اذا استبعدت اسرائيل من الخريطه
اذا استبعدت المشروع الصهيوني من الخريطه
تتغير خريطه المنطقه بلا مبالغه ربما
بنسبه 100%
تخيل كده كل الحروب التي قامت تخيل كل
التداعيات التي ترتبت على قيام دوله
اسرائيل
الامور كانت سوف تتغير بنسبه 100%
حتى اهتمام الدول الكبيره بالمنطقه وخصوصا
الولايات المتحده كان سيتغير
بتراجع
اهتمامها بالنفط كان سوف يظل موجودا لكن
كان في فترات ربما تراجع الاهتمام
الامريكي بشكل كبير جدا جدا
هل اليابان تستقي
تستفيد من عملياتها
في الصادرات ام الاجور في اليابان مرتفعه
جدا فليست مثل الصين انا مش عارفه اقرا
السؤال هل اليابان
معلش عبد الرحمن استاذنك قاعد كتابه
السؤال لا استطيع قراءته
دايما يخطر السؤال على بالي ولا اجد له
اجابه كيف دعمت امريكا ورؤساءه اسرائيل ده
اخونا روبرت ماثيو في بدايتها بناء على
المعتقدات الدينيه مع العلم ان ذلك غير
متوافق مع العهد الجديد فالمسيح فيه
يعني انا فهمت السؤال اللي هو السؤال مكمل
دي قصه طويله
واستاذنك في حلقه على القناه بعنوان لماذا
يخاف الرؤساء الامريكان من اسرائيل سعيت
فيها ان انا
استقصي هذا الاجابه يعني او الاجابه
استقصي الاجابه على السؤال القديم الشهير
لماذا كل هذه المحبه والنفوذ الاسرائيلي
على امريكا
والحقيقه ان في الحلقه دي اللي هي اقل من
30 دقيقه هي خلاصه بحث طويل يعني انما
اكتشفت من هذا البحث
ان ما فيش عامل واحد انما هي مجموعه كبيره
من
ممكن ترجعوا للحلقه حتى لو اكرر ما جاء
فيها من ناحيه ومن الناحيه التانيه ده مش
سؤال حضرتك عشان ما اخرجش بره سؤالك انت
بتسال على تاثير الدين تاثير الدين في
الولايات المتحده
كما فهمته مقتصر على فئه من الامريكان من
الامريكان الانجيليين اللي هم كلمه
الانجيليين بالنسبه للمجتمع الامريكي لان
في انجليين هنا بيقولوا لنا التعبير ما
هواش دقيق يعني ايا كان اللي احنا بنسميهم
في السياسه بعيدا عن التعبيرات الدينيه
اللي ممكن تكون محل جدل هم ما يسمى
بالمسيحيه الصهيونيه اللي بيربطوا مصيرهم
كامه مسيحيه بمصير اليهود
نظريا هم بالنسبه لهم اليهود ليس الا
مؤشرا انه
المسيح سوف يعود وتبدا الالفيه السعيده
اذا تجمع اليهود في ارض الميعاد وبالتالي
هم سعيهم كله
بيتركز على فكره مراقبه ما يجري لليهود
على اعتبار انه تجمع اليهود يعني عوده
المسيح للمره الثانيه
ثم تبدا الالفيه الثانيه ده يعني جانب من
اسبابه اهتمام اسباب الديني بمصير اليهود
دي شريحه لكن هذه ليست كل الاسباب اللي
بتدفع الامريكان للاهتمام باليهود او
اسرائيل في اسباب متعدده استاذنكم ارجعوا
لها في الحلقه اللي هي عنوانها لماذا يخاف
الرؤساء الامريكان من اسرائيل عاوز بقى
يعني بما ان انت اتكلمت على العامل الديني
من الغريب جدا انه اسرائيليين عارفين ان
دي الحقيقه يعني الاهتمام الديني على هذه
الفكره لكن هم لا يمانعوا في ذلك رغم ان
قناعتهم الدينيه تختلف عن ذلك تماما هم
قناعتهم الدنيا ان المسيح لم ياتي اصلا
وانه هم
وطبعا اليهود دول يعني اتجاهات دينيه انما
فيهم اتجاه ديني
واسعه او موجود على الاقل ومهم بيقول انه
اسرائيل ما كان لها ابدا ان تقوم الا بعد
ان يظهر المسيح للمره الاولى وحين يظهر
المسيح للمره الاولى وقتها بقى تقوم دوله
اسرائيل او مملكه اسرائيل والنوع دائما
اليهود الحقيقه بيكفر الدوله الاسرائيليه
ويعارضها وهم دول اليهود المعروفين باسم
يهود ناطوره كارتا يعني
السيد كيف استطاعت الدول
الاسكندنافيه المحافظه على مستوى دين عام
منخفض جدا بالرغم من الازمات الاقتصاديه
في العالم وبالرغم انها لا تملك موارد من
اين تجلب المال انا الحقيقه لا اعلم
تفاصيل الدول الاسكندنافيه الان يعني ما
تبعتهاش كارقام لان بتتكلم على مجموعه من
الدول فانا ما تابعتش الارقام علشان اقول
لحضرتك
اجابه حاضره احنا كنا قلنا في نعرف اقتصاد
ان احنا ان شاء الله نتناولها بس تناول ده
معناه ان يكون عندك الارقام
وظروفهم في الفتره الاخيره فانا لا اعلم
هذا لكن المميز في الدول الاسكندنافيه
ولسنوات طويله ان هم تبوا مدرسه معينه من
مدارس
الراسماليه اللي بيسموها الراسماليه
الاشتراكيه اللي هي راس ماليه وفيها حريه
كبيره جدا للقطاع الخاص ويعني طبعا احترام
الملكيه الفرديه كل الكلام ده لكن في نفس
الوقت بتختلف عن الراسماليات الاخرى اللي
موجوده في بريطانيا والولايات المتحده
مثلا بانه الدوله بتتدخل بشكل كبير بحيث
ان هي تتاكد من مراعاه كل الفئات المجتمعه
الفقير والمريض والعاطل الى اخره فبيسموها
ده نموذج دوله الرفاه او ما يسمى
بالراسماليه الاشتراكيه وده اللي كان
مختلف في هذه الدول
عن تجارب الراسماليه في الدول الاخرى اما
الارقام والتفاصيل فدي محتاجه مراجعه
ومتابعه عشان اعرف ظروفهم ايه من اول
اندلاع ازمه كورونا والى الان
احنا الاسئله جاريه خلينا نرجع تاني من
الاول
السلام عليكم ده وجدي بيقول
هل ترى تباعد امريكا سعودي كبير ما رايك
بتهديدات ولي العهد لامريكا ايضا سمعت ان
امريكا تضغط بشده على السعوديه للتطبيع مع
اسرائيل اتخذ ان التطبيع ممكن في هذه
اللحظه احنا الصوت والصوره تمام ممدوح
ده سؤال جميل يا وجدي وجميل بمعنى مش
الاسئله اللي فاتت ما كانتش جميله لا كلها
جميله بس اقصد السؤال ده يعني هيكون مطروح
في الفتره المقبله
بشده اولا انت السؤال مكون من كذا جزء انا
ما اعرفش ايه هي تهديدات ولي العهد لا
امريكا ولكن اقدر اقول انه في توتر امريكي
سعودي على صعد كتيره وهذا ليس سرا حتى
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
قال من عده ايام ان بيننا خلافات وتباين
في الراء واحنا بنحاول ان احنا يعني نقرب
وجهات النظر وجزء تاني من السؤال بتقول ان
امريكا
بتضغط على السعوديه للتطبيع مع اسرائيل
الاجابه بتاعه الجزء احنا كده عندنا جزئين
من السؤال الجزء التاني سهل خالص ايوه
الولايات المتحده مش بتضغط بقى او اعتبرها
بتضغط بتحاول بتسعى لاقناع السعوديه
بالتطبيع مع اسرائيل
التطبيع ده
هدفه الحقيقي
ببيض اكثر من الولايات المتحده يعني هل
الولايات المتحده تستفيد لو السعوديه
واسرائيل طماعه ده محل نظر وجدال بين
مراكز الفكر المختلفه ومدارس مختلفه في
الولايات المتحده بعضهم يعتقد نعم وبعضهم
لا
انما اللي مش محل خلاف ان ده في مصلحه
مباشره لاداره الرئيس بايدن الذي يريد او
الذي يبحث عن انتصار في السياسه الخارجيه
يدخل به الحمله الانتخابيه
اللي هي تقريبا بدات يعني للانتخابات 2024
وعشان يقول اذا كان ترامب قد نجح في اتمام
ما يسمى بالاتفاقات الابراهيميه اللي ادت
الى عقد اتفاقات سلام بين اسرائيل والمغرب
والامارات والبحرين وفتحت الطريق يعني
لاتفاق سلام مع السودانيين فانا عملت ما
لا يقل عنه بان انا نجحت في اتمام اتفاقيه
السلام بين اسرائيل وبين السعوديه البلد
الاسلامي العربي ذات الثقل الكبير فده
مفيد له
المفاوضات اتكلمنا عنها قبل كده لانه
متوقفه ومتعثره لان السعوديه تشعر ان ده
طلب تتمناه الولايات المتحده طلب تتمناه
اسرائيل فبتحاول ان تحصل على اعلى مقابل
ممكن في مقابل هذا الطلب ما تواتر من
مصادر متعدده ان السعوديه طالبه الاتي
واحد ان هي اتفاق امني تتعهد بموجبه
الولايات المتحده بضمان وسلامه السعوديه
في اي خطر يهددها من خلال من خلال اتفاق
يفكروا فيه ولكن يشبه كده بالضمانات
الامنيه اللي بتقدمها الولايات المتحده
للدول اللي هي موقعه على او منضمه الى حلف
شمال الاطلسي وتحت هذا البند ان تزود
الولايات المتحده السعوديه بصفقات سلاح
متطوره تمنعها عن السعوديه الان اثنين
انه الاميات المتحده تدخل في شراكه قويه
جدا او تقدم دعما كبيرا جدا لانشاء برنامج
نووي السلمي متطور في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
الطلبين محل
جدل يعني تردد من جانب الولايات المتحده
اما بالنسبه
للجزء الثاني من السؤال انت بتقول معلش
لحظه كده من الاسئله بتجري اخونا وانا
اقول لحضرتك اهو
معلش لحظه
ان امريكا السؤال التاني هل تعتقد انه
التطبيع
هل تعتقد ان التطبيع ممكن في اي لحظه لا
اعتقد ان التطبيع انا لا يعني صعب يعني
انا مش متخيل لان السعوديه بتطلب طلبات
تقريبا يصعب ان هي توجب اذا استجابت
الولايات المتحده لهذه المطالب لان كمان
السعوديه حتى مطالب تانيه من بين المطالب
مثلا هي بتقول لازم قيام دوله فلسطينيه
لكن قناعه الامريكان والاسرائيليين ان
الطلب ده ممكن يتغلبوا عليه لان مستحيل
بالنسبه لاسرائيل ان يقدموه اذا هم وافقوا
على اقامه دوله فلسطينيه فهيبقى يعني
تقريبا
فقدوا كل ما سعوا اليه في السنوات الاخيره
من انجازات الانجازات ان هم عملوا عمليات
تطبيع مع دول عربيه دون تحقيق اي تقدم مع
الجانب الفلسطيني وحكايه انه مش يعملوا بس
مفاوضات مع الفلسطينيين بل يتاكدوا من
نجاح قيام دوله فلسطينيه حاجه شبه مستحيله
للاسرائيليين انما الاسرائيليين بيعتقدوا
ان ممكن يتغلبوا على الشرط ده لو هم بداوا
مفاوضات ولو شكليه وفي نفس الوقت لب
ومطالب المملكه العربيه السعوديه يعتقدوا
ان هذا ممكن في كل الاحوال
ردا على سؤالك هل ممكن في اي لحظه هو
نظريا ممكن لكنه ليس سهلا مساله صعبه
تتطلب وقت تطلب تغيرات كثيره خصوصا انه
الحافز لدى السعوديه ليس كبيرا يعني
السعوديه بتحصل على ما تريد الحصول عليه
من اسرائيل بدون اي اتفاق سلام وبدون اي
صداع وبدون اي مخاطرات علشان تغريها
بتطبيع رسمي لازم تقدم لها ثمن كبير جدا
هو دي الاثمان او هذه الطلبات التي طلبها
السعوديون
وبالتالي المساله صعبه انا تقدير ان هم
لطنطلايز الامريكان طنطلايز يعني
يعني بيعشموهم بس لكن لا اعتقد انه هم
جديين او مستعدين لتضيع في المدى المنظور
والا لو كانوا مستعدين لكانت طلباتهم ربما
كانت اقل شويه من هذه الطلبات
وعلى كل الاحوال حتى لو انه هذه الطلبات
يمكن ان تجاب وان السعوديه بتفكر جديا اشك
ان هم ممكن يلبوا هذا الطلب في اداره
الرئيس بايدن الحاليه
تحياتي الله يخليك ده جلال
فيصل مرحبا الله يحفظك احكي لنا عن سوريا
داري مورس طب احكي لك ايه عن سوريا يا
صديقي انت قول وانا تحت امرك اخونا صديقنا
سرفايفر وولف استاذي العزيز اسمي مصطفى
والله كنت لسه سؤالي عليك ده سرفايفر
بيتابعنا من فتره طويله مشكورا يعني اسم
مصطفى واود ان اشكرك كل الشكر على تواضعكم
ومجهودك دائما حق القناه حقا القناه
افادتني كثيرا تستحق كل الجوائز على
محتواها ربنا يخليك ويبارك لنا فيك اخونا
سيرفا شكرا جزيلا يا مصطفى
لماذا امريكا تسعى دائما للتنوع داجوان
لماذا امريكا تسعى دائما للتنوع العرقي
بخلاف كثير من الدول التي تحاول القضاء
على الاقليات في داخلهم وتتمنى اختفائها
هي تسعى ربما يكون الادق لماذا سعه
الولايات المتحده للتنوع العرقي الولايات
المتحده دوله مهاجرين كانت دوله جديده
مساحه ضخمه جدا ثروات ضخمه جدا عدد سكان
في البدايه متواضع كانت فتحت الابواب
لمهاجرين سواء هؤلاء المهاجرين يعني مرحب
به كفاءات علميه او تم استقدامه كعماله
رخيصه او حتى كعبيد لو بتتكلم على التجربه
الامريكيه منذ يعني قرون يعني او منذ نشاه
الولايات المتحده
والنموذج الامريكي قام بعد
بعد الاستقلال الامريكي والدستور الى اخره
على انه الولايات المتحده نموذج فريد
بيقوم بدور البوتقه اللي بيسهر فيها كل
الثقافات وانه عنده القدره بالنموذج
بالحلم الامريكي اللي هو بيقدم دوله قانون
ومساواه حلم الامريكي يعني ايه فرصه
للجميع تبقى مهاجر لبناني بس ممكن تبقى
يعني في اعلى المناصب ممكن تبقى مهاجر من
الدوله اوروبيه زي شوزنيجر وتبقى حاكم
لاهم واغنى ولايه هناك
اللي هي كاليفورنيا ممكن تبقى من اقليات
زي وزير الخارجيه الحالي وتبقى وزير
خارجيه وهكذا يعني فده كان النموذج وده
نموذج اعطى زخما كبيرا للولايات المتحده
لان هذا النموذج استقطب افضل العناصر من
كل مكان في العالم انا بقول ساعه وهي طبعا
ما زال حتى نفس القوانين موجوده تستطيع
الهجره للولايات المتحده بشروط اقل بكثير
من دول اخرى
لكنها الان مع صعود التيار اليميني
المتشدد اللي هو مثلا بيمثلوا ترامب اللي
هو بيضع قيود على الهجره اكثر من غيره
اصبحت
النموذج ده
يعني
محل شك فيه الولايات المتحده بقى في طيار
بيقول امريكا للامريكان طب ومن هم
الامريكان تعريف الامريكان مش ان انت معك
جواز سفر امريكي تعريف الامريكان اللي هو
الامريكي الابيض المسيحي
ده بيمثل تيار هو صحيح ليس طيارا حاكما او
حتى لما كانت ربي موجود بمعنى ان هو لا
يمثل كل مؤسسه الدوله انما هو تيار زادت
قوته في السنوات الاخيره
اسماعيل من الجزائر اهلا وسهلا
اخونا فعل مضارع عليكم السلام
زياره الرئيس الجزائري الى موسكو ماذا
تعني عاوزه دراسها والله انت كويس لان حد
كان بيكلمني عليها النهارده وقال لي كلام
مهم بس محتاج اتوثق منه زياره الجزائر الى
روسيا انما طبعا في اطار عام الاطار العام
ده بيقول لنا انه
بالنسبه للجزائر اعتقد هو محل سؤالك مش
روسي احنا بنتكلم على روسيا كل يوم
بس هنتكلم يعني بالنسبه للجزائر الجزائر
عندها مجموعه من التحديات واحده من
التحديات ديت هي
بمنتهى البساطه يعني هو
المنافسه مع المملكه المغربيه اللي بتزداد
قوه بالدعم الامريكي والدعم الاسرائيلي في
السنوات الاخيره سواء دبلوماسيا او على
الصعيد
العسكري الى اخره وده بيمثل خصوصا انه كان
في الفتره الاخيره في مناورات عسكريه
شاركت فيها المغرب مع الولايات المتحده
وده دفع الجزائريين ان يعلنوا مثلا على
تعبئه على الحدود مع المغرب
في اطار هذه المنافسه اذا حبينا نسميها
منافسه فقط دايما الجزائر بتبحث عن خيارات
اخرى من باب احداث توازن للقوه وطبعا
التوازن والقوه مش هيروح بان انا اذهب
للولايات المتحده ولكن اذهب الى الدولتين
المنافستين اللي هي الصين وروسيا فعلى
صعيد المنافسه مع المغرب اللي هي بتمثل
مصدر التهديد الاستراتيجي الاساسي للجزائر
اللي طبعا بيمتد هذه المنافسه الى افريقيا
يعني ساحات مختلفه هي في حاجه لتعزيز
علاقتها بالروس وبالصينيين لمواجهه
منافستها مع المغرب اللي هي مدعومه من
الولايات المتحده ومن اسرائيل
على صعيد بقى القضايا الاخرى الكثيره
التنسيق السياسات البترول دي مهمه جدا
للجزائر بلد منتج للبترول منتج للغاز
روسيا في حاجه الى تنسيق هذه السياسات
بحيث وان تكون الجزائر يعني تراعي مصالح
الروس اللي هي متاثره بالحق
بالتعاون مع الروس بيمتد الى قضايا كثيره
طاقه نوويه على كل على كل الصعود الحقيقه
يعني لكن
انه
الروس بالنسبه للجزائريين هم داعم رئيسي
في منافستهم مع المغرب وبالتالي هذه
الزياره نقدر ان احنا نشوفها في هذا
الاطار ده الاطار العام التفاصيل تحتاج
الى ان انا اتاكد من بعض المعلومات التي
يعني جائتني واتابع الزياره وان شاء الله
لو تمكنت من التوصل الى جديد نعمل له حلقه
باذن الله
اعمل سلو سلو مود لمنع تكرار الاسلحه
ماندو بيقول لي تم يا عمر اسمه سلو موت
طيب
[موسيقى]
يزن مرجي بحبك من الاردن الله يخليك
ويحفظك يا اخونا
عبده ياسر بيقول ليه مش بتتكلم في الشان
المصري
زمان او ليه مش بتتكلم في الشان المصري
انا بتكلم في الشان المصري الى حد الملل
بس على نعرف اقتصاد
ايه الفكره ان انا لما بتكلمش كتير عليها
في نعرف الام اللي انا بتكلم عليها لان
ببساطه انا فيني نعرف الامه علشان اتكلم
على موضوع بتكلم نعرف الامه الاساس فيها
ان هي بتتكلم على العلاقات الدوليه
بتتكلم على العلاقات الدوليه مش على الشان
المحلي للدول وعليه فانا لما بتكون دوله
عندها سياسات خارجيه مؤثره على الدول
الاخرى فانا بتكلم عنها كتير ليه بتكلم
على تركيا كتير ببساطه لانه تركيا لعبه
دور كبير جدا جدا في بتدخلاتها في ملفات
كثيره في افريقيا واسيا واوروبا وفي كل
مكان ليه مش بتكلم على اليونان بنفس القدر
انها اقل تدخلا سياستها الخارجيه اقل
توسعا من تركيا ليه بتكلم على قطر اكثر من
الكويت لنفس السبب ليه ما بتكلمش على تونس
كتير لانه مشاركتها في الشان الخارجي اقل
من غيرها وفي دول بتبقى دول قويه او دول
مهمه لكن ما هي ايطاليا ما هياش اقل شانا
من تركيا بس تدخل ايطاليا او دورها دور
ايطاليا على الساحه الدوليه
مش زي دور تركيا اللي ارادت ان يكون لها
زي ما بيقولوا بالانجليزي افنجران
مصر على مدار السنوات الاخيره والسنوات
الاخيره ديت هي اللي طلعت فيها القناه في
2016 او اخر 2015 منتفخه الى حد كبير جدا
على نفسها بتحاول ان تعالج مشاكلها
الداخليه اللي اهمها حاجتين مشاكل
اقتصاديه بتحاول تعالجها ومشاكل تتعلق
بحمايه حدودها ومصالح امنها القومي
المباشره جدا يعني مثلا حمايه مواردها من
مياه النيل مثلا حمايه حدودها من اي
ارتباك او اي مشاكل في غزه او ليبيا او
السودان فالتدخلات محدوده وبتحاول انها
تنسق ده مع دول الجوار الاقليميه اللي هي
شركائها زي دول الخليج على سبيل المثال زي
بعض شركائها الخارجيين بس فقط انما مصر
مثلا الان ليست هي مصر في الستينات حين
كان جمال عبد الناصر بيتدخل في كل دوله في
ارجاء العالم هذا هو السبب انا وان النشاط
الاساسي لمصر هو الشان الاقتصادي فانا
تقريبا بنتحدث عنها كل اسبوع تقريبا فارجع
لنعرف اقتصاد وانت تعرف وليس هناك اي سبب
اخر يدعوني لعدم الحديث عن مصر يعني
محسن افضل قناه يوتيوب محتوى عربي شكرا
جزيلا لك سيد جوبيل بوركت ده انا اصلا
اقول لك شكرا جزيلا وفي نفس الوقت انا
اقرا كلامك بتقول شكرا اخوك محسن السماحي
ربنا يخليك يا محسن الله يحفظك محمد
سيد تعليق سيد تعليق على تهديد السعوديه
لامريكا انا ما اعرفش السعوديه هديلت
امريكا بايه قولي يمكن انا قرات التصريح
ما اعرفوش انا متابع الشان السعودي
الامريكي بشكل جيد بس ما هي التهديدات في
علاقه متوتره في خلاف على قضايا كثيره انا
ممكن لو اتكلمنا عليها يعني ممكن ناخد
الحلقه كلها بس لو انت بتتكلم على تهديد
معين قولي عليه بحيث ان انا لا اجيب على
سؤال انت لم تطرحه
استاذ سيد عندي سؤال لماذا هناك دول مثل
المانيا حجم صادراتها مقارب من حجم صادرات
امريكا او اقل قليلا ولكن الناتج المحلي
الامريكي اكبر بخمس مرات منها هي طريقه
الحزب غير دقيقه يا استاذ عبد الرحمن
انت لما بتتكلم على صدرات دوله ده معيار
وبتتكلم على الناتج المحلي الاجمالي لدوله
قصه تانيه الناتج المحلي الاجمالي له
طريقه حسبه في حل عن الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي على نعرف الاقتصاد ولا نعرف الام
اتكلمنا عنه كتير انما هو باختصار انت
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي او الجي دي بي هو
المعادل النقدي القيمه النقديه لاجمالي ما
تنتجه بلد ما من سلع وخدمات في فتره زمنيه
معينه وفي تلات طرق لحسابه لكن ده باختصار
ما تنتجه من سلع وخدمات يبقى ممكن انا
هعمل للانتاج المحلي فقط يعني امريكا
بتعتمد اكثر على الاستهلاك المحلي ان انا
بنتك وعندي 330 ولا 340 مليون امريكي
باستهدفهم بالدرجه الاساسيه ثم اصدر بلد
زي الصين بيعتمد على التصدير ثم الانتاج
المحلي كل بلد عندها نموذج وبالتالي مساله
الصادرات
مختلفه شويه عن الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
ممكن يبقى عندي ناتج محل ضخ جدا لكن
صادراتي متواضعه زي مين زي الفرق ما بين
صادرات الولايات المتحده ونتجاه المحلي
نتيجه ان هي الصادرات مش هي هدفها الاساسي
او يعني هي بتخاطب السوق المحلي اكتر بلد
زي الهند بغض النظر عن عدد سكانها الضخم
الا ان النتيجه لمحل حوالي ثلاثه تريليون
دولار بس ثلاثه تريليون دولار دول بقطع
النظر انهم قليلين بالنسبه لحجم السكان
موجهين اكثر
للانتاج والانتاج الموجه للاستهلاك المحلي
علشان يشفع 104 المليار و400 مليون هندي
في بلدانغافوره صدرتها ضخمه جدا ليه لان
هي
بتصدر لنفسها وغيرها اكثر بتقوم على ان هي
مثلا تاخد سلع تاتيها من الخارج وتعمل
عليها
مثلا همم
قيمه مضافه صغيره تعبئه تعليق تغليف يعني
وتعيد التصدير مره اخرى فتبقى خانه
الصادرات
ضخمه جدا يعني مقارنه بنتها المحلي مش
عارف اذا كنت وضحت لك ولا لا ولا اراك
انما اتمنى يكون يعني
الفكره واضحه وهتبقى اوضح لو انت رجعت
تاني لحلقه الناتج المحلي الاجمالي على
نعرف اقتصاد
هل يا ترى ان دول النيتو تعمل على الدخول
المباشر للحرب في اوكرانيا تتمنى ان لا
تدخل الحرب ابدا ولكن يا ابراهيم واحد من
التطورات الخطيره في تطورين خطيرين في
الحرب في اوكرانيا
لو تذكروا ان من حوالي سنه او اقل قليلا
انا قلت لحضراتكم ان هذه الحرب حين بدات
ما بين روسيا وما بين اوكرانيا المدعومه
من الغرب كان هناك خطان احمران واضحا الخط
الاولاني ان تظل الحرب داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ولا تتسع خارجها لا تتسع الى
خارجها يعني لا يتم استهداف العمق الروسي
ولا اطرافها يعني ولا من جانب قوات
اوكرانيا اللي هتعمل ده بدعم من السلاح
الغربي ولا تقوم روسيا بضرب دول
المجاوره لاوكرانيا والداعمه ليها اللي هي
بتنتمي لحلف شمال الاطلسي اي ان تظل الحرب
موجوده على الجغرافيا الاوكرانيه
الا يساهم الحلف شمال الاطلسي في قتل جنود
روس بشكل مباشر يعني ما يجيش جنود امريكا
او حتى يعني او جنود من حلف شمال الاطلسي
ويساهموا في قتل جنود روس
بشكل مباشر الخطين الاحمرين دول تلاشى
ووجدنا انه بدايه من مايو 3 مايو الماضي
ثم في الاسابيع الماضيه بدا الهجوم يطال
الحدود الروسيه وكان هناك درون على افتح
قوسين تبقى من الخط الاحمر هذا الخط يعني
الا يتطور الحرب الى العمق الروسي ولا
يتجاوز الجغرافي الاوكرانيه انه الامريكي
ان الاوكران انكروا انهم يفعلون ذلك
انكروا انهم يهاجمون الحدود الروسيه
وقالوا دول
معارضين روس ساقطين على النظام انكرت
الولايات المتحده انها تدعم اوكرانيا
وانكرت انها تشجعها فضلت هناك حجامات كلنا
والجميع يعلم انها ملعوبه من اوكرانيا ومن
الولايات المتحده والغرب لكنهم كلهم
يتنصلون فالخط الاحمر تاكل وان ضل نظريا
قائما
الخط الاحمر الثاني برضو تاكل بطبيعته
لانه علشان انت لا تقتل جنودا رؤوس مش
بالضروره تجيب جندي لابس ازاي الامريكي
وتقتل جندي ولكن انت اعطيت الاوكران
اسلحه بدات دفاعيه ثم هجوميه ثم هجوميه
متطوره جدا فاصبح من السهل جدا على الجند
الاوكراني ان يقتل جنودا روس وقد قتلوا
عشرات الالاف من الجنود الروس واصبح الان
الروس بيتحدثوا علنا على ان هذه حرب متورط
فيها حلف شمال الاطلسي افتح قوسين
الامريكان يقولون النيتو يقول انه نحن لا
نشارك في هذه الحرب نحن نعطي اسلحه
للاوقاد فقط للدفاع عن انفسهم لا اكثر ولا
اقل فسقط الخط الاحمر الثاني عمليا ولكنه
بقى نظريا الخلاصه ايه الخلاصه انه احنا
عندنا
ان حلف شمال الاطلسي الذي يتمنى ولا يمكن
يفكر وهو في كامل وعيه لا هو ولا الولايات
المتحده منفرده طبعا ولا حلف شمال الاطلس
المجتمع ان يدخل في صراع مفتوح هو بيعتمد
للاسف او احذف كلمه للاسف انا هوصف بعيدا
عن الاسف هو اغراه الصمت الروسي اللي بدا
بان هو يعني هم تحسسوا لرد الفعل الروسي
لما بداوا
يحاولوا يخترقوا الخطين الاحمرين دول مع
طول امد الحرب ووجدوا ان رد الفعل الروسي
ليس بالشده التي توقعوها في البدايه
فبداوا يزودوا تقدم الامداد الاوكراني
باسلحه اكثر تقدما فاكثر تقدما وهكذا
بداوا يغضوا الطرف او ربما يشجعوا
الاوكران على الهجوم على الحدود الروسيه
فالصمت الروسي اللي اللي مبني على مجموعه
من الاعتبارات يطول شرحها
حلف شمال الاطلسي بان الخطوط الحمراء
للروس ليست فعلا ستركت ولا قويه وده
اغراهم بتجاوزها بشكل ما ليه الروس تجاوزه
او غض الطرف عن الخطوط الحمراء في مجموعه
من الحسابات واحده منها ان روسيا يعتقدوا
ان الوقت في صالحهم انه لو ردوا هجوما
عنيفا جدا سوف يدفعهم ذلك او يورطهم في
حرب مع الف شمال الاطلسي لا يحلم بها
قناعتهم من الوقت بيصفهم بمعنى انه هم
احتلوا تقريبا خمس الاراضي الاوكرانيه
صاحب بتكلفه عاليه جدا انما نجحوا في
احتلال نصفي
عشرين او 25 في البيع من الاعراض
الاوكرانيه يعتقدوا ان الاقران
اجهده انه الانتخابات اللي هتيجي في 2024
سوف تحمل متغيرات في الغالب سوف تصب في
صالح الروس هكذا يؤمرون ان الانتخابات
اللي هتعقد متتاليه في الدول الاوروبيه قد
تاتي بحكومات يعني
تعبر عن
التوجه شعبي بانه ان دعم اوكرانيا في
اوتيل وغير مجدي
بيعتقدوا ان الاوروبيين والامريكان نفسهم
سوف يكونوا اقصر ولذلك في بعض المحللين
بيقولوا ان بوتين قد اعد العده انه ان
يخوض حرب ليس عمليه عسكريه صغيره ولكن حرب
زي ما بقول واحد داري يعني طويله جدا جدا
جدا جدا جدا جدا ولكن
منخفضه الكثافه يعني يدير الحياه في روسيا
كانه لا توجد حرب وفي نفس الوقت هذه الحرب
تستمر لفتره طويله عشان تنجح هذه
الاستراتيجيه ان كانت توصيف دقيق هذا يعني
انه
او احد شروط نجاحها انه
لا يكون هناك خسائر ضخمه جدا في الجيش
الروسي اكثر مما حدث انه لا تحدث انتكاسات
عنيفه انه لا يحدث تململ داخل المجتمع
الروسي اللي يشعر ان في خسائر كبيره بين
ابناؤه ان ما يكونش فيه كوارث اقتصاديه في
روسيا والحقيقه انه
يعني انه
احنا بنتكلم على حسبه هشه جدا يعني ممكن
الخطوط الحمراء
الامريكان بيعتقد او الغرب بيعتقد انه
الروس تساهلوا فيها قد تؤدي الى كارثه بان
الاوكران مثلا عن قصدنا او عن خطا يقوموا
بعمليه تستفز الروس باكثر مما ينبغي فيكون
الرد عليه فتتصعد الحرب او انه
[موسيقى]
انه
ان المسائل تخرج عن السيطره نتيجه انه في
ازمات اقتصاديه في روسيا
والازمات الاقتصاديه دي تؤدي الى تململ
الشعب الروسي وبالتالي ده ممكن برضو يؤدي
الى تغير في مسار الحرب
السلام عليكم ده حسين
ولدت شعبي بيقول مشكلتكم على المغرب مشكله
مع المغرب ايه ما عنديش مشاكل مع المغرب
انا زرت المغرب مره واحده احبها كثيرا بلد
جميل جدا
لو كان لي ان يعني دائما انا بقول كده
لاصدقائي لو كان لي ان اخطر بيتا خارج
بلدي دول محدوده احب ان استقر فيها من
بينها المغرب اه والله يعني بلد جميل جدا
وكانت زياره القصيره في بلد جميله وعملت
علاقات طيبه مع بعض الكتاب وبعض الشخصيات
العامه
ما عنديش مشكله مع المغرب فما اعرفش ليه
عند حضرتك تصور ان لدي مشكله معها يعني
عميد مساء الخير استاذ سيد لماذا لم نعد
نسمع كثيرا عن مبادره الحزام والطريق وهل
تعثر هذا المشروع ام انه ما زال قائما
مشروع الحزام والتاريخ ما زال قائما ولكنه
مشروع عملاق كبير جدا جدا
بحيث انه
لوس لدفين يعني يعني
ما هواش مثلا انت هتبني زي مثلا طريق بري
ضخم من اسيا يربط اسيا باوروبا واحد في
اسيا الوسطى مثلا فتراقبه يوم بعد يوم ده
انت بتتكلم على طرق كثيره متعدده بريه
وبحريه وعلى الطرق ديت المفهوم الطريق
واسع جدا طريق بري طريق بحري طرق
شركات طيران خطوط طيران خطوط ملاحه بحريه
حاجات ضخمه جدا موانئ قواعد عسكريه هتبقى
في المستقبل فتقريبا كل السياسه الخارجيه
الصينيه تقدر تدرجها تحت مظله الحزام
والطريق طبعا هذا المشروع العملاق الضخم
اللي يعني
كبير جدا الى حد ان انت يصعب ان انت
تراقبه بدقه ولكن هو وترته بتصعد وبتقل
على حسب نسب النمو اللي موجوده في الصين
لما بيكون في فائض بيستفاد لما بيقل
الفائض نتيجه مثلا فتره الكورونا
والاخلات بتقل قليلا لكن المشروع قائم
ومهم جدا للصين ثم ان بعض الاقتصادين
الصينيين بيقولوا ما لناش حل تاني ما انت
عندك قالت انتاج هي الاكبر في العالم قالت
الانتاج دي عاوزه تواصل انتاجها علشان
تواصل انتاجها هتلجا الى وسائل منها ان هي
تستهدف السوق المحلي بعد شويه هيلاقي ان
هم كونوا طبقه وسطى الطبقه الوسطى بيزيد
استهلاكها هذا جيد انه يرفع الفقراء من
الفقر هذا جيد لكن ايضا يحتاج الى التوسع
الخارجي علشان يفضل هو اكبر شريك تجاري
لكل دول العالم وقادر على انه دائما يفتح
اسوان جديده بحيث ان الاله الانتاجيه
الضخمه ديت لا تتوقف على السوق المحلي
وحده
ما حقيقه الموقف الامريكي استراتيجيا من
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع ومن هم
رجالات امريكا في السودان انا اقدر اقول
لك يا استاذ محمد انا يعني حكايه رجالات
امريكا انا مش عارف اذا كان لامريكا اصلا
رجالات في السودان او رجالات في كثير من
الملفات امريكا
يعني
اتسع الرتقه على الراتب كما يقولون زي ما
قلت لحضرتك هي يعني امبراطوريه كبيره
عندها اهتمام بامور كثيره بس يعني لان كل
حاجه تهم الولايات المتحده فهي تهمها
بمعنى ايه مثلا يعني لو انت قلت له ان
السودان انقسم الى تلات اربع دول لو قلت
له ان السودان قرر انه يتحد او يعود وحدته
معاه جنوب السودان دايما هيكون لي راي بس
مش الى الحد اللي يخليه مثلا يبعت الاسطول
الامريكي علشان يتدخل في السودان مش لدرجه
انه هو يقرر مثلا انه يخصص 20 30 مليار
دولار يحل بها ازمه السودان مش حاجه يعني
لكن بالنسبه له ان انا عندي مبعوث بيتناقش
مع السعوديين
للتهدئه في السودان وعنده مجموعه من
الخطوط الحمراء منها مثلا اتاكد انه
مثلا ان القاعده مش هتنشط في في السودان
اتاكد انه الروس مش هيبقى لهم قاعده على
البحر الاحمر اتاكد ان الايرانيين مش
هيكون لهم موطئ قدم قوي هناك
اهداف ودي بيوكلوها وبيطلبوها من اصدقائهم
لانه الدول الخليجيه مثلا او مصر او الدول
الافريقيه الاخرانيه ده يا مصالح تتشابه
بعضها مع المصالح الامريكيه فبيطلبوا
هؤلاء من شركائهم
انت عندك بلد زي تونس
مثلا مشاكلها كلها تتحل لو حصلت على اتنين
ونص مليار دولار اتنين ونص مليار دولار
لكن هل الاتحاد الاوروبي بقى هل الولايات
المتحده عشان ما نخرجش بره الموضوع هتستعد
تدفع الاتنين ونص مليار دولار ابدا وهتفضل
تونس تعانق لانه الامريكان يقول لك
ليه طيب مدينه تبقى مشكله اقرب الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي ما يعالجها الاتحاد
الاوروبي يدفع لهم انا هتدخل في تونس لو
اصبحت المشكله عنيفه جدا امتى المشكله
عنيفه جدا انه راحوا للصينيين والصينيين
مثلا اتفقوا مع التونسيين على ان هم
يعملوا لهم مشاريع بنيه تحتيه وموانئ وعلى
البحر المتوسط او اعطوا قاعده عسكريه
للصينيين او الروس مساله تنتقل كده من شان
بعيد عنا الى مساله حيويه لنا ويبتدوا
يتدخلوا لاكثر ولا اقل
هل اوباما يمكن يرجع للحكم لا ما هو قضى
فترتين وهذا هو الدستور الامريكي الا اذا
تم تغييره السلام عليكم احمد وعليكم
السلام
نايف هدف الرساله امين اسعد الله مساك
ربنا يخليك يا امين هل العراق الحق في ان
يقاضي اميركا على كل الجرائم التي
ارتكبتها في العراق وما السبب الذي يمنعهم
من ذلك السبب ان امريكا هي القانون الدولي
هترفع اضيع فين على الولايات المتحده
اولا اولا يعني
يعني مثلا محكمه العدل الدوليه واللي
بتحاسب الناس على جرائم الحرب امريكا ليست
عضو فيها اساسا وليه مش عضو فيها
لانها ببساطه تدرك انه جيوشها في كل مكان
في العالم واكيد جيوشها تورطت في جرائم
حرب وبالتالي لو هي صدقت على هذا معناها
ان هي ممكن تلاحق صح ان ده عمره ما يحصل
لدوله كبيره بدليل ان روسيا الان
الامريكان ساعدوا اوكرانيا وساعدوا الدول
الاخرى على
ادانتها بارتكاب جرائب حرب ورائسها الان
مطلوب للتحقيق هل يتخيل يعني انه يمكن
لمحكمه العدل الدوليه ان هي يمثل امامها
بوتين مثلا وارد ولكن
يعني ردا على سؤال حضرتك الدول القويه
بتعمل القانون الدولي ده علشان تخدم
مصالحها مش عشان تخضع له خصوصا الولايات
المتحده الامر الثاني
انه كثير من المصالح العراق في يد
الولايات المتحده فمن غير المعقول انه
العراق لو افترضنا ان هناك قضاء دولي على
مستقل وهذا غير قائم لانه ايه القضاء
الدولي ده يعني انت مجموعه من المحكمين
موجودين على ارض دوليه اللي عندهم لا جيش
ولا عندهم غيره هم كل الحكايه بيعتمدوا
على انه غيره وينفذوا هذا الحكم بيقولوا
مثلا ان في زعيم دوله
فقيره ضعيفه في اسيا والامريكا اللاتينيه
مدان فدوله اخرى بتقوم بالقبض عليه
وارساله بس مين اللي هيقوم بقى يجيب
مسؤولين امريكان ويقبض عليهم ويوصلهم ثم
لو بغض النظر ان ما فيش يعني قانون دولي
فوق يعني عنده هذه القدره على انفاذ
احكامه ما العراقيين وغيرهم عندهم مصالح
جامعه مع هذه القوه العظمى فلا يستطيعوا
اغضابها
تقرير التضخم في امريكا نزل 4% هل دي
نهايه التضخم والله نتمنى ذلك بس لسه
المساله النهارده وانا داخل كان البنك
المركزي الامريكي سوف يعلن البيانات لم
اطلع عليها لان انا كنت دخلت
اكتمال بنك الفيدرالي الامريكي وارتباطه
باسعار الذهب في اتجاه الصعود ام الهبوط
محمود يا محمود ده احنا عملنا اكثر من
حلقه على هذا استاذنك ارجع لها بالتفصيل
على نعرف اقتصاد ولكن الاجابه القصيره الى
الحد المخل يعني انه انت عندك لما تزيد
اسعار الفائده في الولايات المتحده معناها
انه اسعار السندات يعني اسعار القروض
الولايات المتحده بترتفع امريكا طول الوقت
بتقترب بتقترض من داخل امريكا ومن خارج
امريكا من خلال اذون الخزانه والسندات
والاثنين واحد بس السندات فترات طويله
واذون الخزانه فترات قصيره اقل من سنه
سواء اذن او سلانا سندات لما بتزيد
الفائده لان التضخم مرتفع عاوز تحاربه
فبترفع اسعار الفائده لما بترفع اسعار
الفائده هتعمل ايه يعني هتطرح على السندات
بدل ما بتقترض زي مثلا بخمسه في الميه
تقترض بسته في الميه ما دام ما تقترض بسته
في الميه اللي عنده فلوس يقول انا اضع
اموالي فين في الاسهم ممكن اكسب واخسر ولا
اضع اموالي في السندات الامريكيه مين اللي
بيقول كده كبار المستثمرين من كبار
المستثمرين اللي هم كبريات المؤسسات
الماليه صناديق المعاشات والبنوك اللي هي
بتستثمر اموال الافراد العاديين لك طب انا
اروح احط في السندات فبيسحب جزء من امواله
في الاسهم اللي فيها نسبه مخاطره الى
السندات التي ليس فيها مخاطره وفيها نسبه
ربح جيد اتنين انا اشتقي الذهب والذهب في
حد ذاته قيمته الوحيده انه ينفع واحد في
فتره الاضطرابات البنك المركزي او البنك
العادي او المستثمر اللي هيشتري دهب
هيستفيد منه ايه عاوز يشتريه رخيصا وينتظر
حتى يغلوا فيبيعه بس وده بيلجا له كوسيله
للتحوط لما يشوف انه الدولار او او الوضع
في الولايات المتحده مضطرب والرؤيه مش
واضحه فيقول لك حول جزء من اموالي
للاستثمار في الذهب
هذه العلاقه فاستاذنك ارجع
اكتب كلمه ذهب على نعرف اقتصاد هتلاقي
اكثر من حلقه يعني بتتكلم بالتفصيل مع
صديقي هاني
السلام عليكم ماذا عن التطور السياسي في
السعوديه كنت تقصد انه يعني انه سياسات
الخارجيه السعوديه
ولا تقصد السياسه الداخليه السياسات
الداخليه
يعني ما في شك انه فيها تطورات
معظمها يدعو للاعجاب لان انت السعوديه
تحولت من بلد مغلق
يعني
مغلق على مستويات مختلفه كل ما يعرف في
السعوديه ارتبط ذهنيا بانها اكبر منتج
للبترول او اكبر مصدر للبترول وانها يعني
قبله للسياحه الدينيه فقط لا غير الان
السعوديه ارتبطت في اذهان الناس
لامور كثيره جدا وده تحدثنا عنه هذا في حد
ذاته ايجابي
الرغبه في تنويع الاقتصاد معناها الرغبه
في زياده التعليم معناه الرغبه في فتح
مسارات اخرى للانتاج وللتنميه كل هذا امر
جيد الرغبه في تنويع في في تنويع تحالفتها
بحيث انها ما تكونش بس مرتبطه بحليف واحد
كما حدث لعشرات السنوات مع الولايات
المتحده هذا يدعو الى الاعجاب
امور كثيره تدعو للاعجاب في السعوديه ولكن
طبعا كل شيء له
ودي قصه تحتاج ان احنا نتكلم عنها بقى في
حلقه
مستقله يعني لانه
مع الحريه مع هذه التطورات على المدى
البعيد هكون في تغيرات هتؤدي الى تغير في
ثقافه السعوديين تدريجيا انت هتستقبل سياح
هتستقبل ثقافات مختلفه لازم التغيرات اللي
بتحصل هتطال مناخ
الثقافي كله وهتجد جنسيات مختلفه بثقافه
مختلفه وملابس مختلفه فتلاقي السعوديه
تدريجيا بتشبه بلدان المجاوره مثل
الامارات هل السعوديين كلهم متقبلين لهذا
المساله ماشيه في هذا المسار اثنين انه
التحرر الاقتصادي هيبقى في افضل حالاته
لما يبقى في كمان نسبه حريات اكبر سياسيه
ودي مساله هتحتاج ان هي المسؤولين في
السعوديه يراعوها على المدى البعيد بحيث
انه كل الانفتاح الاقتصادي المحتمل او
اللي هم بيسعوا اليه هيكون مرتبط برضو
بنموذج في نسبه تحرر اكبر من الوضع الحالي
الموجود
بو ابراهيم اين تتوقع ان تتجه حرب روسيا
واوكرانيا
هل تعتقد ان تصل الحرب
الحرب الى الحرب العالميه الثالثه اعتقد
انه اذا حذفنا كلمه الحرب العالميه
الثالثه لانه ده يعني يعني الاجابه
المختصره كل شيء ممكن انما اتوقع ان
المساله تسوء بشكل كبير جدا جدا لانه اسوا
ما في الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه انها
موجوده في ايدي سياسيين
ذاهبه عن حقيقه الاخطار اللي موجوده يعني
الامريكان بيتكلموا كل يوم انه في مشكله
كبيره مش الامريكان الامريكان دي كلمه
كبيره كتير من الامريكان والمراقبين
بيتكلموا على خطر
سياسه الولايات المتحده في اوكرانيا ما هي
سياسه الولايات المتحده في اوكرانيا الذي
كان ظاهرا وواضحا ان هم
او المعلن انه دعم اوكرانيا الى النهايه
حتى تحقق النصر او حتى يفشل الروس في
تحقيق اهدافهم في اوكرانيا هذا هدف غير
محدد يعني يعني ايه تعريف فشل الروس ان هم
يعملوا ايه طيب وايه هو مفهوم ان انت
ان الاوكرانيا يحقق النصر يعني مثلا يسترد
كل الاراضي قبل 24 فبراير 2022 معنى ذلك
انه الاربعه او الاقاليم التي ضمها الروس
الى روسيا الاتحاديه يتم اعادتها من
الجنود الروس علشان تعمل الخطوه دي كم
تحتاج كم من الدعم تحتاجه اوكرانيا لهزيمه
الروس
والاوكران اللي بيدعموهم في اوكرانيا كم
من الدعم المالي كم من الاسلحه كم من
الوقت
طيب ورد الفعل الروسي اذا اذا يعني
الاوكران حصلوا على كل هذه الاسلحه ونجحوا
فيها تصعد هائل عشرات الالاف من القتلى
احتمالات مخاطره كبيره نفترض ان الاوكران
فعلوا ذلك وان الروس خسروا وقبلوا
وانسحبوا الى 24 الامريكان ما بيتكلموش
على كده والاوكران الان لا يتحدثون عن ذلك
ده بيتكلموا مش على حدود ما قبل
24/2022 ده بيتكلموا على حدود ما قبل 2014
ايتم اعاده ضم شبه جزيره القرم من الروس
وبالتالي احنا قدام اهداف غير محدده وقدام
اطراف الامريكان مش محددين اهدافهم ومش
هيحددوا اهدافهم قبل عقد الانتخابات وهذا
هو الجزء المحسن في المساله ان المساله
خاضعه للانتخابات بالدرجه الاولى بوتين في
وضع الان لا يستطيع ان
يسعى بجديه الى وقف الحرب اذا اوقف الحرب
الان سوف يجد عشرات الاسئله اللي بتشكك في
جدوى ما فعله اين انفقت اين ما جد وكل
عشرات المليارات التي انفقها الامريكان
لدعم الاوكران
هل لتحقيق
تفاوض على المائده والروس مازال حتى الان
هم اصحاب الكعب الاعلى رغم خسائرهم
الكبيره هتجلس على مائره المفردات هتحصل
على ايه لن تحصل على شبه جزيره القرم لن
تحصل على شرق اوكرانيا لن تحصل على امور
كثيره
يعني مما انت بتقول ان ده هدفي الموجود في
اوكرانيا
وبالتالي هو مش هيقدر يوقف الحرب الان هو
سايب المساله لانه المسائله زي كده لما
بتيجي تسال كوتش كوره يا ماندو مش كده
يقول له انت خسرت جوله واتنين يقول له
احنا العبره بايه بنهايه الموسم احنا
الحساب مش بالقطعه فهو مستني بقى المساله
لما تنتهي الانتخابات ولكل حادث حديث يجرح
الى السلام
يجنح للمفاوضات وجد ان الفرصه معتالي انه
ممكن يستمر في الصراع فالمساله مفتوحه
هل من الممكن ان تتحدث عن احداث 30 يونيو
لا ما اقدرش لانه ما عنديش حاجه جديده
اضيفها غير ان انا استرجع احداث شديده
الالم
عاوز اقول ايه يعني فيها مساحات رماديه
كثيره جدا يعني غائبه كتير من الوثائق لم
تظهر كثير من الحقائق لم تتضح وبالتالي
حديثي عنها لن يكون حديثا يضيف كثيرا يضيف
كثيرا للي يجي بعد بقى او اذا ربنا اعطانا
العمر ادي كمان عشره 15 سنه تكون الوثائق
اتضحت والحقائق كلها اتضحت
ودعاش فتره صغيره يعني لان في وثائق ما
بتظهرش قبل 30 سنه خلاف ذلك هتبقى عباره
عن اهواء حد شايفين اللي تم فيه 30 يونيو
هي اعظم انجاز في التاريخ الحديث واخرين
يرونها ان هي حدث
بالغ السوء والقبح فيعني انا اذا ما كانش
لدي جديد اضيفه فافضل ان لا اتحدث عنها
يعني بشكل مكثف واشك ان في يعني حد باحث
جد يعني يكون راغب في انه يتحدث عن 30
يونيو في هذه الفتره لانه الاحداث ما زالت
ساخنه
والمشاركين في 30 يونيو مع ضد مازاله
قائمين في السلطه او في المعارضه يعني
وبالتالي ما فيش حقائق تقدر تاخدها كده
بعد الاعصاب ما تقدر يكون مره على الحدث
فتره كافيه
السلام عليكم استاذ سيد هل برايك
عندما تقول دول بوضع موازنات انفجاريه
ستؤدي للتضخم كما في موازنه العراق
طب ما هو السؤال سامحني مش عارف
هل برايك عندما تقوم ايه بقى
معلش يمكن السؤال محذوف يا محمد
دراما كيف استطاع بشار الاسد رغم انه رئيس
ضعيف بدون قرار سيادي دولته فاشله ان يرفض
طلب الروس بلقاء اردوغان بدون شروط وكيف
رفض ايضا طلب الامريكان بتسطيب اثنين من
مواطنيهم الصحفيين المحتجزين في سوريا منذ
سنوات وانت بنيت افترضت وبني عليه انه
بشار الاسد هو رئيس ضعيف
ليس له قرار السيادي
احنا اتكلمنا على صديقه اكثر من مره سواء
فيما يتعلق بالرئيس بشار الاسد او دول
اخرى مش لازم اكون الهند مش لازم يعني
اكون الصين مش لازم اكون روسيا عشان
يعاندي القدره على المناوره مع الدول
المختلفه
رئيس دوله عنده القدره عارف انه بلده
محل اهتمام من دول اقليميه ومن دول كبرى
بيعمل ايه نتيجه ان الجميع في حاجه الى
سوريا فهو بيناور بين هذه الدول ما هو ما
فيش دوله هتيجي يعني تحط المسدس في راسه
تقول له خد القرار ده دلوقتي حالا الروس
عشان يكون لهم قاعده عسكريه او عشان
يجددوها محتاجين موافقه من الرئيس بشار
الاسد فيضغطوا على بشار الاسد وبشار الاسد
يضغط عليهم بانه بعلاقات مع الايرانيين
بعلاقات مع الدول الخليجيه
بتهديدهم بان انا ممكن استجيب وافتح يدي
او اتعاون معاه الامريكان الامريكان لهم
مطالب ايه المطالب اللي عاوزينها من بينهم
ان هم يتم الافراج عن السجناء هو يقول لهم
انتم عايزين افراج لكم على السجناء انا
محتاج ان انتم تجمدوا قانون قيصر ماذا
يملك الامريكان ان يفعلوه اذا فعل ذلك
بشار الاسد يعني هيقوم مثلا بقصف القصر
الجمهوري
مش هيعملوا ان هم يقولوا هل هل مطلبنا
يساوي فكره الطلبات اللي بيطلبوا
ادي المساله باختصار فيعني انت وصيف اللي
انت حاطته يجعل السؤال ملغز جدا بس
الحقيقه المساله لا تتم على هذا النحو
قل لي يعني الناس عاوزه ايه قبل ما يطور
مثلا كوريا الشماليه سلاحها نووي لماذا
كلها حتى مع السلاح النووي يعني السلاح
النووي ده تطور في الفتره الاخيره يعني
كوريا الشماليه لماذا هذه الدوله الصغيره
الفقيره تحظى بكل هذه الاهميه في منطقه
اسيا والعالم والقياس على كده كتير يعني
دول كثيره ممكن نتكلم عليها نقول هي ازاي
بتمارس
او المسؤولين فيها بيلعبوا دور على الساحه
الدوليه ضعف امكانات دولهم
ليه مثلا بلد زي جيبوتي رفضت ان يكون في
قاعده عسكريه موجوده للروس مثلا لما روسيا
دي دوله عظمى جيبوتي رفض لايه لانه هو
عارف ان الكل عنده قواعد عسكريه على اراضي
وبالتالي ان علشان دوله عشان يقبل لازم
الدوله تقدم له امتيازات واذا دوله ضغطت
عليه باكثر مما ينبغه يروح لدوله اخرى
وهكذا يعني
ما رايك بالهجوم الاوكراني المضاد حتى هذه
اللحظه
ما رايك بالهجوم الاوكراني المضاده حتى
هذه اللحظه كيف ترى
الضغوطات على اوروبا هل وهي وهي ترى
اسلحتها المتقدمه وهي تحترق ما هي ده اللي
احنا كنا لسه بنتكلم عليها يا صديقي
الهجوم المضاد بنسمع كلام من المحللين
الروس والمحللين الاوكراني ومن الغربيين
ما فهمت حتى هذه اللحظه ان الهجوم المضاد
اللي الروس بيقول لكل قال ان هو خلاص بدا
ولروس حددوه ليوم اربعه يونيو الماضي يعني
من حوالي عشره ايام حتى هذه اللحظه
لم يخرج عن توقعات الاوكران انفسهم
الاوكران المسؤولين الاوكران قالوا نعم
سوف نبدا هجومنا المضاد ولكن هناك توقعات
اكثر مما ينبغي من
دول العالم الخارجي ده هم اللي قالوا كده
مسئولين يعني مستشار لوزير الدفاع ووزير
الدفاع ومسؤولين في الحرب قالوا سوف نقوم
بالهجوم افتح قوسين
كان شرط اساسي لدول حرفه شمال اطلسي وائل
الولايات المتحده سوف نواصل الدعم
والولايات المتحده على وجه التحديد ولكن
عليكم ان تقدموا شيئا يبرر كل هذه
المساعدات ثم كانوا مضطرين الى القيام
بهذا الهجوم المضاد الهجوم المضاد حتى
الان نتائجهم محدوده لا يوجد تغييرات حتى
هذه اللحظه تذكر في تغيير يعني
موازين القوه على
على ارض المعركه هل يحصل دافي المستقبل
الله اعلم بس عشان يحصل معناها انه هيكون
في تغير كبير يعني الامريكان حلف شمال
الاطلسي هيزودهم بمزيد من الاسلحه
المتقدمه واذا حصل هل هيظل الروس يعني
متمسكين بفكره
الانتظار
لازم نصبر قليلا لانه الوقت في صالحنا اشك
عمر بيقول
سلام عليك يا استاذ تحياتي لك من الجزائر
اريد معرفه معنى التضخم الاقتصادي معنى
التضخم الاقتصادي الكلمه الشهيره جدا اللي
بيرد عليه اللي بيلخصه علماء الاقتصاد
تو ماتش ماني
تشيسنج
اموال كثيره جدا
تطارد سلع قليله جدا اذا وضعت هذه القاعده
وكتبتها الان 2 ماتش
اموال كثيره جدا تطالع تطارد بضائع قليله
جدا هتقدر تكتشف ان في طرفين للمعادله ديت
ان التضخم يتحقق في حالتين اذا زالت
الاموال بشكل كثير جدا او اذا قلت البضائع
بشكل كثير جدا متى تزيد الاموال بشكل كثير
جدا في عده حالات اهمها ان دوله تبال في
الاقتراض تصرف في الاقتراض انت بتقترب في
ظرف في دول عاوزه تقرضك لان عندها فائض او
لاي سبب يعني فانت بالغت في الاقتراض
الاموال ديت حطيتها في مشروعات كثيره جدا
المشروعات الكثيره جدا ديت عباره عن رواتب
عباره عن اجور للموظفين بقى عندهم اموال
كثيره
بينزلوا لسه ما انتجتش المشروعات ديت
وربما لا تنتج ابدا بقى انا بقيت احصل على
اموال من مشاركتي في المشروعات ديت اللي
هي عباره عن مدن كباري طرق او حتى مصارع
لم تنتج والنتيجه ان انا بنزل اشتري ما هو
الانتاج لسه ما زادش فترتفع الاسعار او
اكثر من كده
ان انا لا اجد من يقرضني فاطلب من البنك
المركزي في بلدي انه يطبع اموال فيطبع
اموال فيبقى عندي الاموال ديت فابتدي ان
انا ادخها في السوق يعني امول بها مشروعات
الناس تاخد الاموال تنزل بها كل واحد في
جيبه فلوس كتيره جدا ينزل على السوق يلاقي
نفس السلع والخدمات كما هي هذا هو الجزء
الاول الجزء الثاني ان تقل البضائع ان
يحصل تعطل كبير في الجهاز الانتاجي لاي
سبب لاي سبب ثوره امت مثلا زي ما حصل
الثورات الربيع العربي فتعطل الجهاز
الانتاجي الى حد ما مثلا انه يحصل
ركود كبير
نتيجه انه في مشكله في سلع رئيسيه زي
البترول الى اخره انما الحاجه بقى اللي هي
يعني بيقولها مجموعه من الاقتصاديين ان
الجزء الثاني اللي هو قله البضائع تيادي
الى تضخم وارتفاع في الاسعار مؤقت
انما اللي يعمل تضخم بعيد المدى هو الجزء
الاولاني اللي هو كثره الاموال ليه قالوا
لانه
نفترض ان في قله في المعروض لو في قله في
المعروض وبرضو السيوله قليله ما فيش فلوس
الناس مش هتقدر تشتري يعني انا البضائع
كانت موجوده زي ما هي وانا معي فلوس كتيره
فبنزل اشتري طيب لو انا ما عنديش فلوس
والبضائع موجوده مش هعرف اشتري هيحصل نقود
طيب انا ما عنديش فلوس والبضائع قلت مش
هشتري يعني وبالتالي بيقولوا ان اللي يعمل
او الاعتقاد لدى شريحه كبيره من
الاقتصاديين ان الركود ان التضخم اسف
بيحصل بشكل رئيسي ولفترات طويله حين تزيد
السيوله لما تزيد الاموال اللي في المجتمع
الاسباب اللي انا ذكرتها ديت او لاي سبب
باكثر من قدره المجتمع على الانتاج
هل يا ترى وضحت لك يا عمر
ريمورس ماذا عن سوريا ومستقبل سوريا والله
سؤال كبير ما عنديش اجابه مختصره عليه
انما ليس انا اسف يعني ليس لدي ما يدعوني
الى التفاؤل لو بتسالني انت كمواطن اذا
تخيلت اذا تخيلت انه
سوريا
الان
[موسيقى]
توقفت
او بداوا مفاوضات لحل كل مشاكلها الرئيسه
ما هي مشاكلها الرئيسه واحد انه مشاكل
العشره العشره في الميه من الاراضي التي
احتلها الاتراك الان مصيرهم ايه مشاكل
التلاته ونص مليون او اكثر الموجودين في
تركيا
والملايين الموجودين في الدول الاخرى
ويبحثوا مصيرهم واذا وجدت ان الحكومه دخلت
فيهم مفاوضات النعم منطقه الحكم الذاتي او
الاداره الذاتيه في شمال شرق مع القرد
واذا اعتقدت انه
السوريين بداوا في مفاوضات مع الدول التي
تقاطعهم في الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات
المتحده وبعض الدول العربيه زي قطر الى
اخره
اذا افترضنا ان كل هذه المفاوضات بدات
هتحتاج الى سنوات علشان
تحل كثير من المشاكل مش كل المشاكل
وبالتالي فكره التنميه وانه سوريا تبتدي
تضج فيها الحياه مره اخرى وتتحل كتير من
مشكلتها الضاغطه على انها تحتاج الى سنوات
طويله جدا اذا بدا الحل من الان واذا
افترضنا ان في توافق دولي على حل بشكل
سوري او هذا التوافق الدولي غير موجود
واتمنى ان يخيب الله ظن يعني
من افضل القنوات شكرا لك شكرا يا محمد
السلام عليكم استاذ سيد هل روسي عاجزه عن
توريد الاسلحه لزبائنها زبائنها زي مين
يعني
هي الاسلحه بيتم الاتفاق عليها ثم بتسعى
لانتاجها الان هي طبعا مشتركه في حرب
وتحتاج الى اسلحه
تستخدمها وفي اسلحه لا يفترض منطقيا يعني
داخل الاسلحه التي تريدها لنفسها لانه في
احتمال شمال الاطلسي في اي وقت وعليه
[موسيقى]
يعني
افتراضك يبدو منطقيا انثى فوتس بالتفكير
للمره التانيه هل اذا مثلا بلد زي الجزائر
بلد زي مصر بلد زي
اللي هند اذا طلب شحنه سلاح الان من من
نوع معين من الاسلحه المتطوره هل الروس
قادرين على امدادهم بهذا السلاح الان
محتاج محتاج تفكير هل مثلا الدول دي تدفع
مسبقا ويتوسع بعض المصانع اللي اسلحتها
متوفره لدى الروس ولديها ما يكفي الان وهي
عندها القدره ان هي تشغل المصانع للتصدير
ده سؤال هل يعني يتوقف على وضع او المخزون
الروسي من الاسلحه المطلوبه هل لو هي ما
عندهاش وخلص هذا المخزون لديها من انواع
معينه من القذائف او الصواريخ وطلباتها
الهند ولا الجزائر ولا غيرهم هل من
المعقول ان هي تلبي هذه الاحتياجات وفي
نفس الوقت هي في حاجه اليها ولا تبحث عن
نموذج اخر وهي
توفير هذه التكنولوجيا اللي مش حرجه قوي
للدول دي بحيث ان هي تصنع في الدول اللي
هي بتطلبها مساله محتاجه تدقيق فيها يعني
انما اقول اكيد هيكون في ضغوط على قدره
الروس على التصدير في هذه الفتره
بتعمل ايه يا ماندو
طيب اخونا مصطفى
استحود على البث المباشر كله استاذ سيد
حكومه استاذ سيد حكومه كندا وهولندا
تتقدموا بشكوى لمحكمه العاده الدوليه ضد
النظام نظام المجرم بشار الاسد ما الهدف
من ذلك بعد 12 سنه من الدرع الثوره
السوريه
وهو انت انا انا انا ما اعرفش المعلومه ان
كندا وهولندا تقدموا لكن اقدر اتفهم انه
ما زالت حتى الان
في تيارات اصله هولندا
البلد اللي انت قلتها ايه كندا والولايات
المتحده ودول اوروبا الغربيه بتحكمهم
احزاب والاحزاب ديت عندها التزامات تجاه
ناخ بيها خذ مثال ابسط واشهر لما جاء
الرئيس بايدن للسلطه جاء بدعم من عده
طيارات من بين هذه الطيارات ما يسمى به او
اليسار التقدمي اللي هو حريص جدا جدا على
ان تلعب الولايات المتحده دورا كبيرا في
الدفاع عن حقوق الانسان من في كل مكان في
العالم اقليات نساء
متحولين جنسيا مضطهدين اقليات دينيه
اقليات عرقيه الى اخره وعنده التزامات قدم
لهم وعودا وبالتالي بيجد صعوبه جدا في
النقوص عنها كذلك نفس القصه في دول
الغربيه مختلفه انه هذه الدول ومنها كندا
لا اعرف عنه هولندا اللي انت تحدثت عنها
ولا اعرف انهم مقبوب هذه الخطوه على وجه
التحديد لكن اذا قاموا فانا متفهم ده لانه
في دول كثيره بتعتقد انه ان التزماتها
الاخلاقيه سياستها الخارجيه ان تبنى على
التزام اخلاقي هتفتح قوسين تقول لي ما
الدول ديت ما يهمش غير مصالحها بس النخبه
اللي موجوده فيها
قدمت برنامجها الانتخابي ان هي هتفوز على
هذا الاساس وبالتالي
علشان تحافظ على وعودها الانتخابيه بقدر
ما تيسر بتعمل ده حفاظا على الاقل على
مصالح النخب واذا ما كانش في مصالح له نخب
والقضيه مش هتاثر على مصالحه الخارجيه ما
المانع ان هي تعبر عن
رؤيه اخلاقيه فعلا وتلتزم بها مدام تنفيذ
هذه الرؤيه الاخلاقيه لا يتعارض مع
مصالحها الماديه
وبعدين انت بتقول ليه هم هيعملوا كده بعد
12 سنه طب ليه قطر بتعمل كده انت بتسال
على هولندا وبتسال عن كندا طب ما تسال عن
قطر يعني قطر اللي ليها مصالح مباشره في
المنطقه او لان انت تسال ليه بعد 12 سنه
بتقول انه مشكلتنا مع هذا النظام الذي
اجرم في حق شعبه سياسه قطر مبنيه على ان
انا اكون دوله ترسم صوره ذهنيه في عقول
الجميع انها دوله مختلفه دوله لا تقدم
مصالحها الضيقه على مبادئها وانها دوله
بتسعى ان هي تكون
داعمه لحقوق الانسان وهكذا يعني افتح
قوسين وتصادف كمان ان مصالحها ان ان هذه
الرؤيه او هذه الشخصيه اللي بتحرص انت
ابنها من خلال سياساتها الخارجيه تتوافق
مع مصالحها المتضرره من وجود بشار الاسد
الذي يعرقل المصالح الخارجيه
القطريه داخل سوريا وفي كل مكان اخر ان
تمكن من ذلك
ممكن لو دققت بقى في الحالتين اللي انت
قشطه اليهم واللي انا ما اعرفهمش قد تجد
ان في تفاصيل اخرى تتعلق بمصالحهم برضو
اللي لا التي لا تتفق مع وجود بشار لكن
انا لا اعلم هذا
استاذنا الكبير اهلا بك يا ريت تكون تقول
اخره الازمه الاقتصاديه في مصر امتى
وموضوع انضمام مصر للبريكس من عدمه الجزء
التاني من السؤال سهل يا شريف الانضمام
مصر تقدمت مع مجموعه كبيره من الدول مش بس
مصر يعني ولا السعوديه الجزائر دول كثيره
تقدمت الى مجموعه البريكس اللي هم عباره
عن خمس دول
ومجموعه بتدرس فكره هي حتى الان لم تفتح
عضويتها يعني انما بتدرس التوسع وبتنظر في
ملف كل دوله وعاوزه تختار دول بمواصفات
معينه ان تضيف لدول البريكس ان تكون سوقا
كبيرا واعدا يمكن ان يضيف الى قوه البريكس
وعليه ما فيش اجابه محدده لسؤالك هذه
الدول تقدمت وتنتظر
الجزء الاولاني من سؤالك متى تنتهي الازمه
الاقتصاديه المصريه لا مفيش
يعني مثلا اقول لك ايه انه في موعد معين
ممكن تنتهي فيه ولكن احنا الازمه ايه في
ازمه صغيره عاجله ضاغطه وفي ازمه كبيره
الازمه الضاغطه ان مصر تستطيع ان توفر
تمويلا يمكنها من دفع استحقاقاتها في 2023
و2024
هذه الاستحقاقات بتسعى الحكومه من تحقيقها
من خلال واحد البحث عن قروض والبحث عن
قروض بيبدا بان هي توجد اتفاقا مع صندوق
النقد الدولي صندوق النقد الدولي له شروط
والحكومه بتحاول تلبي هذه الشروط ولكن
بشكل متدرك حتى لا تؤدي تلبيه شروط صندوق
النقد الدولي لاضطرابات الاجتماعيه رفع
كبير جدا في اسعار الوقود خفض كبير جدا في
قيمه الجنيه بتحاول تعمله المساله هتاخد
وقت اتنين من خلال بيع اكبر عدد ممكن من
الاصول المملوكه للدوله لمستثمرين اجانب
وغير اجانب
على امل ان ده يعطيها اموالا تحل بها
مشكلتها الان وهي سايره في هذا الاتجاه
[موسيقى]
اذا نجحت في هذا الاتجاه طبعا هتكون انه
هتتجاوز مصر مشكلتها وهذا هو المرجح ان في
النهايه مهما كانت الازمه يعني
شديده من الاقرب الى المنطق انه خصوصا ان
مصر عندها اصول كثيره يمكن ان تكون مغريه
للمشارين لا اتخيل ان المشكله دي هتكون لا
يمكن تجاوزها اعتقد ان هم هيتمكنوا من
تجاوزها ايه المشكله العاجله وبتشبه فيها
دول اخرى زي مشكله تونس ايضا عندها اقتصاد
جيد عندك اقتصاد جيد مش مش وحش يعني
وتونس عندها اقتصاد جيد ولكن مشكلتنا الان
في حاجه الى خمسه مليارات دولار او تحديدا
اثنين ونصف مليار دولار لان في اتنين ونص
بتقول انا قادر على تربيته عشان تحصل
عليهم لازم تروح للصندوق والصندوق عشان
يوافق او الشروط والشروط ديت الحكومه
هتؤدي الاضطرابات الاجتماعيه وهكذا
المشكله الاكبر بقى انه ازاي وما تقدر
توصل الى حل اللغز القديم لماذا لا تحدث
تنميه كبيره في الاقتصاد المصري لماذا لا
تقول لدينا قطاع زراعي كبير زي فرنسا مثلا
او زي روسيا لماذا لا تكون لدينا قطاع
صناعي كبير زي دول يعني بدات معنا واحنا
تخلفنا عنهم كثيرا لماذا لا تكون لدينا
مصر تكتذب مثلا استثمارات مصر دايما كان
الاستثمارات الاجنبيه بتتكلم على كام يعني
عشره 15 مليار دولار في السنه
لماذا لا يكون لدينا استثمارات اجنبيه
خمسين وستين وسبعين ومئه مليار دولار
سؤال ابسط مصر البلد اللي هو عنده البحر
الاحمر والبحر المتوسط وثلث اثار العالم
القديمه واثار اسلاميه
ليه عنده عائد السياحه كله احنا بنتكلم
على عشره 12 مليار دولار في السنه ليه ده
ما بيحصلش هذا هو السؤال اللغز اللي
الحكومات المختلفه لم تجد حتى الان
[موسيقى]
او الوصف السليمه انك تعمل عمليه
الانطلاقه دي تعملها ازاي حتى الان
الحكومات المتعاقبه لم تنجح فيها وبتتعثر
لاسباب يطول شرحها
ما راي حضرتك في
لا مش هنا
شكرا جزيلا لك ما مدى جديه بوتين في
انسحاب روسيا من اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب
وهالرده فعل وهل هو رد فعل على تدمير السد
عبد العظيم
اللي يهم بوتين انه يحصل على مقاتل اللي
يحصل على مقابل بين تصدير الحبوب انه حبوب
وتصدر انه مصالحه تراعى اذا وجد انه هذه
المصالح رعيه كما في فترات يعني نسقت فيها
الحكومه التركيه هيعمل ده اذا وجد انه لن
يستفيد شيء ربما يقصر عمليه هذا الاتفاق
على دول محدوده من التقاؤه يعني
السلام عليكم ان اصبح سد النهضه امر واقع
للابد ام ما اعتقد عمر انه اصبح ام
را واحد مستر استاذنا الكريم
لماذا استخبارات بعد انتهاء ولاياتهم
يتسلمون وزاره الخارجيه حدث ذلك مع مايك
بومبيو ايضا
هكفيدان وزير الخارجيه الروسي كان رئيس
المخابرات
بالنسبه للامريكان
هو اصلا عضو كونجرس يعني هو رجل سياسي
اللي كان عندهم منصب سي اي اي او وزير
الدفاع هو منصب سياسي يعني لا يتطلب ان
يكون جنرالا او رجل امن وبيكون منصب سياسي
اما رجال الامن فهما موجودين ثابتين في
وزاره الدفاع سواء
كمدنيين بيلعبوا دور في وزاره الدفاع او
كعسكريين وكذلك الاستخبارات الامريكيه
فيها من كل الخلفيات مدنيين وعسكريين
وغيره لكن رئيس وزاره الدفاع او رئيس
المخابرات هو منصب سياسي قد ياتي من
من كونوا من اي خلفيه يعني
لم ياتي الى لم ياتي لوزاره الدفاع لانه
كان رئيسا هو قتل
وزاره الدفاع باعتباره سياسيا
جمهوريا بارزا ارادوا الاستفاده منه في
موقع سي اي اي ثم في وزاره الدفاع
لعب دور نشط جدا
في كونوا رئيس مخابرات واراد الرئيس
التركي ان يستفيد من خبراته كرئيس
المخابرات اسوار اساس المخابرات في كل
الاحوال وخصوص المخابرات العامه عليها
كثير يعني من سوء الفهم رئيس المخابرات هو
رئيس جهاز
معلوماتي يعني
هو جهاز تحليلي ما هواش مثلا هو ارتبط في
اذهان الناس بانه يعني جهاز فيه كثير من
الاكشن والعمليات السريه لكن هو في الاساس
هو جهاز معلوماتي
بيحاول يحصل على المعلومه بطرق مختلفه
ويقوم بتحليلها بشكل جيد ده هو دور وزير
رئيس المخابرات العامه في اي دوله ولذلك
مش غريب ابدا ان هذا الرجل ينتقل الى
مواقع سياسيه اخرى باعتباره ان هو في
الاساس هو رجل معلومات وليس رجل امن يعني
فقط كده او رئيس مثلا وحدات للقوات الخاصه
او غيره يعني
ما راي حضرتك في الانتخابات الرئاسيه في
مصر لا اعلم عنها شيئا مضارع
وحتى الان لم اجد اي مرشح جاد يعني يعلن
عن رغبته في الترشح استاذ سيد ممكن
بالمختصر ان تشرح لنا الجوانب السلبيه
والايجابيه للحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه على
كل من الصين وامريكا على حده
ونتمنى حلقه منفصله عن هذا والله ده ممكن
طبعا ده جيد جدا بس انا هقول لحضرتك
باختصار شديد جدا بالنسبه باختصار
بالنسبه للاطفال السلبيه الاول على الروس
ان الروس تضرروا بشده لانه
هذه الحرب جعلتهم معزولين بشكل كبير جدا
جدا عن عن الدول الغربيه ده واحد
الحرب دي دفعه الغرب ان يبحث عن بدائل
لاهم
صادرات الروس وهي البترول والغاز ثلاثه ان
الحرب ديت حتى هذه اللحظه لم تحقق اهدافها
الحقيقيه في ان هي تجعل
اوكرانيا
بعيده عن النفود الغربي دخلتها في قلب
النفوذ الغربي فده باختصار شديد بالنسبه
للصين هي تقريبا فرضت حربا ومواجهه مبكرا
مع الغرب للصين يعني فرضت موجه مبكره بين
الصين والغرب كانت الصين تتمنى ارجائها
وتوفرها
اولويات اهم بالنسبه للصين يعني كانت
تتمنى ان تكون هذه المواجهه مفاجاه حين
تسعى الصين اذا قررت ضم مثلا
تايوان الان غزو الروس لاوكرانيا جعل
الغرب يعني
يستعد لكل الاحتمالات الممكنه ويجري كل
السيناريوهات الممكنه اذا فعلت الصين نفس
الشيء فنبهت الغرب بشكل مبكر اكثر مما
ينبغي لاي تحرك صيني في اتجاه
تايوان ثم ان هي برضو وضعت الصين مع الروس
في جبهه واحده رغم انه الصينيين كانوا
يتمنوا ان يظلوا على مسافه ابعد شويه من
الروس بالنسبه للولايات النسبه الاوروبيين
تضرروا على سبل المختلفه يعني وكشف ضعفهم
وعجزهم عن ان هم يدافعوا عن مصالحهم
وتضررت اقتصاداتهم الى اخره يعني انت ما
سالتش عن الاوبين على كل حال بالنسبه
للامريكان
الاضرار الكبيره هتكون بعيده المدى خذ على
سبيل المثال دول كثيره الان ومنها الصين
يقول لك انا ليه استثمر اموالي في
الولايات المتحده
واضمن سلامه هذه الاموال ما ممكن يفعله
كما فعله الامريكان ويقوموا بتجميد
الاموال الروسيه في بنوكهم ليه انا استثمر
في السندات الامريكيه والبنوك الامريكيه
وممكن اخضع العقوبات لا لاي شيء انا عملته
يخالف القانون الدولي مثلا او القانون
الامريكي لمجرد ان هو اعتبرني خطرا عليه
هتجد انه اللهجه او التوجه في التخلص من
الدولار والبحث عن بدائل بدا بشكل قوي جدا
نتيجه تغول الامريكان
ويعني استغلالهم المفرط في سياده الدولار
ضد روسيا ثم الصين في الفتره الاخيره ده
هيضر اكيد الدولار والسياده الامريكيه على
المدى البعيد خد عندك الدول العربيه اللي
ادركت في اثناء الازمه قد ايه نفاق
الامريكان وكمان دول افريقيا ان الولايات
المتحده ديت قوه منافقه تريد ان تجعل
قوانين العالم كلها على مقاسهم فقط فبدات
دول كثيره تدير ظهرها للولايات المتحده
ومثال الدول العربيه بارز جدا وتحدثنا عنه
سابقا كثيرا فواضح ان هذه الحرب هيكون من
بين نتائجها على الولايات المتحده هو
تراجع وضعها كقوه كانت بتتمتع بتتمتع بوضع
شبه منفرد على سياده العالم الان هي
بتنافس دول اخرى على قياده العالم
خمس دقائق ونكتفي يا صديقي
عندنا اسئله كتير
لماذا مصر دوله
مخلفه او بمعنى اخر لماذا لا نتقدم ما لسه
كنت بتكلم يا اسامه خالد كلمه متخلفه يا
خالد مع الاقل علينا يعني ولكن احنا
هو في ناس بتبحث بيسموهم ايه من
المتخصصين في الافكار النهضويه انه يجي
كده يقول الدوله دي مشكلتها ايه طبعا
السؤال
كبير جدا فما بتلاقيش اجابه مختصره يعني
انت مش بتسال المكنه دي عطلانه ليه فقول
لك انا والله اصلي في سوفت وير عطلان في
غرض واير عطلان لا انت بتقول بلد بالكامل
ليه البلد ده ما بيحققش تقدمه طبعا انت
محتاج في الاول في الاجابه ان انت تحدد
تعريفك للتقدم بس انا مش هخش في الحاجات
النظريه دي او لكن تقول انه مصر 105 مليون
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي لها مثلا في حدود
400 مليار دولار رقبت واضع جدا
انت بتسال ايه هي الصناعات المتقدمه عندك
ايه هي صدراتك الحيويه للعالم هي وهكذا
حجم الاستثمارات اللي بتستقبلها لسه كنت
بتكلم هتجد ان على كل المؤشرات
بصفه عامه تقول ان مصر قدامها مسافه طويله
جدا
نعيد الى سؤالك بقى ليه ما بنحققش ده دي
مساله
مش ان هي مش بس مش يعني لم تتحقق انا اشك
ان هي مطروحه بوضوح في هالناس كتير لانه
طوال الوقت المسؤولين في الدوله مشغولين
بمشكله مؤقته يخرجوا منها الى مشكله مؤقته
عشان كده لما كان حد بيسالني من حضراتكم
على الازمه الاقتصاديه بقول احنا قدامنا
مشكلتين مشكله عاجله وملحه وهيجاد موارد
لسداد الالتزامات العاجله على مصر ودي انا
واثق باذن الله ان هي سوف تحل حتى وان كان
بتكلفه كبيره التكلفه الكبيره ديت اللي هي
ارتفاع الاسعار لكن
يقين ان مصر هتتوازن تظل المشكله الكبيره
هي انه ليه الاقتصاد المصري ليس دائما
ماذوم وفي افضل حالاته لا يعاني من
التزامات ملحه عليه للعالم الخارجي دي قصه
ليست مطروحه بشكل كبير على المجتمع المصري
على المسؤولين المصريين وكنت اتمنى ان ده
يكون القضيه الرئيسيه اللي موجوده على
موائد الحوار الوطني ولكن يعني الحوار
الوطني بدا بمبادره من الدوله والدوله
بتديره
بطريقتها يعني يعني ده مش حاجه نابعه كده
من المؤسسات وكثير من المؤسسات هو بيدين
في وجوده للدوله موجود في النقابه لانه
الدوله بتدعمه موجود في الحزب المعارض لان
الدوله بتدعمه فالدوله بصراحه بتخاطب
الدوله هذا ليس في صالح الدوله ولا في
صالح المسؤولين ولكن
اللي في صالح الدوله الشعب الدوله
المسؤولين هو ان يكون في حوار حقيقي تتفتح
السما بيكتب تتفتح الابواب وانه تسمع
الاراء وانه يتحط هدف واضح الهدف الواضح
ده ان احنا عندنا مثلا سؤال لحضرتك احنا
عندنا السياحه عوائد السياحه متواضعه يكون
في حوار حقيقي بين الناس اللي هم بيشتغلوا
في الساحه وقولوا لنا ليه السياحه في مصر
بتفضل عند هذا في حلقه حاجات تتحل وحاجات
صعبه تتحل الحاجات اللي تتحل قدامنا مشكله
واحد اتنين تلاته نحلها وفي مشاكل مش
هنقدر نحلها لانها مرتبطه بامكانيات ضخمه
فبتاكد وتوضع بس الحقيقه ده عشان يوضع
لازم يكون المسؤولين عن السياحه او لتحقيق
هذا الهدف وليس فقط اتوا لانهم مثلا
[موسيقى]
محسوبين على اصحاب النفوذ الكبار او ان هم
من الموالاه وليس من المعارضه فده طبعا
اذا انطبق على اي وظيفه اخرى الوظيفه
الاخرى ديت لن تتطور اذا جئت بنقيب لمجرد
ان هو بيدعم الدوله
هيكون مشكلته انه يرضي الدوله مش يرضي
اعضاء النقابه اللي هو بيمثلها ونفس
الكلام بالنسبه للوزارات انا ساني جدا جدا
وانا بتكلم على
المابسه بتفرج على التلفزيون ومن كام يوم
وجدت ان وزير الاثار مع وافر الاحترام ليه
مصر على ان يكرر شكر وتقديره لرئيس الدوله
طب انت اصلا زميلي رئيس الدوله باعتبارك
وزيرا مسؤولا في جهاز تنفيذي ما حاجتك الى
ان تاتي وتصر على كل هذا النوع من يعني
المديح اللي هو الحقيقه في غير محل وانت
قول انا مشاكلك كذا لكن انت مشغول وهو
وعدد من الوزراء هو مشغولين بمديح الرئيس
احنا عندنا مشكله اغرب انه رؤساء الاحزاب
المعارضه اللي هي ليست الا واجهات لناس
عاوزه تتكسب مشغولين بمديح الرئيس كان
لدينا ظاهره في مصر لا تظهر الا في دول
يعني تتعجب انه مرشحين للانتخابات يقولوا
ان احنا بندعم الرئيس وما عندناش مشكله
معاه واحيانا يقولوا انا مستعد ان اعطي
صوتي له مساله تبدو وكاننا في سرك يعني
ما عنديش اجابه تانيه يعني محتاجه انه
الاجابه باختصار وطبعا انت اكيد مش محتاج
ان انا هقول لك واحد اتنين تلاته في ناس
اعلى مني كثيرا بس الفكره انه يطرح
المساله دي ناخد قطاع قطاع احنا عاوزين
نحسن الصناعه ايه مشاكل الصناعه بس فعلا
حسن المشاكل الصناعه ونقول ادي مشاكلنا
نقدر نحل واحد اتنين تلاته وده صعب
لكن هذه المشاكل عاده اللي طرح على هذا
النحو وتدخل فيها تضارب مصالح وتدخل فيها
وجود شخصيات هي لا تسعى للحل بقدر ما تسعى
للحفاظ على كراسيها وطريقتها للحفاظ على
كراسيها هي بالمداهنه
يعني انها تقول كلام لطيف لاصحاب النفوذ
والمسؤولين الكبار في الدوله ورئيس الدوله
فقط لا غير اتمنى ان يتغير هذا من خلال
الحوار الوطني اللي بيجري واتمنى ان تكون
قضيه مطروحه اثناء الانتخابات المقبله
هل سيزور الرئيس التركي مصر على المدى
القريب والتقب الرئيس السيسي كلام منطقي
جدا انه يحصل لان هم بيقطعوا مسافات واسعه
هل اليابان
تستقي عملتها المتدنيه من الصادرات ام
الاجور في اليابان
معك داوود امير اتمنى ان تعرض وجهه الاردن
في القضيه الفلسطينيه اتذكر في حلقات
سابقه تكلمت عن القضيه وذكرت ان الموضوع
من ناحيه الاردن مختلف الى الان اطالب
بشاشه اكبر
لراحه حضرتك او اقلها كاس
اه خلاص انا فصلت الى كتر خيرك يا اخونا
ديفيد شاشه اكبر او اقلها كاس ماء ادي كاس
الماء شكرا جدا ليه يعني
والشاشه الاكبر حاضر
هو موقف الاردن مختلف
هديك اجابه قصيره وبعدين نتكلم اصله
الاردن مثلا تختلف عن ايه عن باقي الدول
تختلف مثلا عن دول الخليج تختلف ازاي عن
دول مثلا المغرب العربي تختلف حتى عن مصر
ان الاردن دوله صغيره نسبيا وطبعا انا قلت
لكم كثير لما بوصف
يعني اي حاجه سلبيه دوله صغيره يعني
مساحتها صغيره وعدد سكانها صغير بنتكلم في
حدود 9 مليون اظن
والعشره مليون مساحه صغيره جدا وهي تجاور
يفصلها نهر عن دوله مقدسه قويه بالسلاح هي
اسرائيل ولديها اطماع في المملكه الاردنيه
فتاريخ المملكه الاردنيه اللي هو طبعا او
تمريخ الاسره الهاشميه تاريخ كل حكام
وكانوا بيسروا على خط رفيع جدا جدا جدا ما
بين
تحقيق مطالب الاردنيين اللي فيهم عدد كبير
جدا نزح مباشره من الضفه الغربيه الى شرق
نهر الاردن وبالتالي عنده مشاكل واضحه مع
الاسرائيليين اكثر من مشاكل واحد مصري زي
بيراقب القضيه وبيعتبرها قضيه مبدا ده
بالنسبه له مبدا ومصالح وارض انتزعت منه
وما بين محاوله انه يسيطر على هذه المشاعر
الغاضبه
بدبلوماسيه لانه غير مستعد للدخول في حرب
هو واثق ان هي لن تكون في صالح ه اذا
دخلاها مع دوله نوويه عندها كل الاسلحه
ودوله عدوانيه
فدائما عنده هذه الموازنات بتخليه يجري
كثيرا من المفاوضات السريه كثيرا من
التفاهمات الغير مكتوبه يعني
عشان كده هي وضعها مختلف هي هتلاقي وضعها
مختلف حتى في كثير من القضايا يعني دوله
مثلا
كانت من الدول القليله جدا اللي مثلا رفضت
ادانه صدام حسين اثناء حربه مثلا على
الكويت
لانه كان عنده راي عام داخلي من
الفلسطينيين خايف من رد فعلهم الغاضب اللي
كان مؤيد لصدام حسين خايف من قطع البترول
اللي بياتيه من صدام حسين يعني فهذا هو ما
اقصده بانه الاسره الهاشميه لها ظروف
مختلفه
الى متى تستمر الازمه السوريه
اجبنا على هذا السؤال ما هو افضل حل
للقضيه الفلسطينيه في ظل الظروف الحاليه
لا يوجد حل جيد ابدا في ظل ظروف الحاليه
لانه اسرائيل لا تريد اي حل غير مستعده
لاي حل
هل
ستستعلو فعلا جبهه الشمال مع الكيان
الصهيوني في المستقبل عمر تقصد يعني جبهه
الشمال يعني لبنان
المفروض ان في تهدئه في المنطقه تهدئه في
المنطقه يعني الدول اللي كانت على خلاف مع
ايران الان هي بتحسن علاقتها مع ايران
وسواء دول الخليج الخمسه الماعدا حتى الان
البحرين والمفاوضات كلام على البحرين مع
الاردن معه مع مصر مع المغرب
الاتجاه ذاهب الى التهدئه وليس الى الصراع
حتى الان ولكن ما بين طرفه عين وانتباهتها
وبدل الله من حال الى حال
يكفي تصريحات حول ان امريكا هي من شجعت
الدول العربيه للتحاور مع ايران
لا اصدقهم هل من الممكن ان يدخل الغاز
الايراني اوروبا
والله المانع ما هو اذا نجح للاتفاق اللي
هو
الاتفاق اللي بتجريه في مفاوضات سريه الان
بين ايران وبين
الولايات المتحده الان الاتفاق ده بيحاول
يسعى الى تحقيق اتفاق مؤقت بموجبه
تجمد
اتفاقها النووي مؤقتا
وترفع الولايات المتحده جزءا من العقوبات
الى ان يتوصلوا الاتفاقا اكبر وبموجبه يتم
الافراج عن
ه او السماح لها بتصدير ليه بتصدره على كل
الاحوال وبعلم الامريكان ولكن بشكل رسمي
ما الذي يمنع وخاصه الاتحاد الاوروبي اخذ
خطوات اكثر من الولايات المتحده في فتح
طريق مع ايران ما الذي يمنع انه يبقى في
خط انبوب يصل من ايران الى تركيا الى
العالم العربي دي مساله ميسوره وسهله اذا
اترفع الفيديو الامريكي
اخونا اكس ارشا انا اسف مش عارفه اقرا
الاسم اخي انت افضل شخص في ساحه المحللين
والله كلامك يا جميل جدا ومقنع جدا سؤالي
هل تتوقع ان يفوز ترامب في الانتخابات
القادمه وان فاز ماذا يمكن ان يتغير في
العالم اولا اشكرك على الكلام الطيب كثر
الف خيرك سامحني اذا كنت قريت الاسم غلط
لانه انت كاتبه يعني يا ريت تكتبوا اسمك
عادي يعني بالانجليزي او بالعربي
فيما يتعلق بالسؤال الاولاني
فيفتي قائم جدا عنده فرص كبيره
انا انا تقدير انها اكثر من 50 شويه يعني
لانه لو تجاوز المشاكل القضائيه ودي محل
خلاف بين القانونيين وانا مش قانوني يعني
وانما انت جوزها فاظن يعني الان على الورق
باداء بايدن قد تكون لديه فرصه تزيد على
ترامب على بيض اللي عنده مشكله كبيره اذا
كان هو المرشح الرئيسي للحزب الديمقراطي
وفي الغالب هو المرشح الرئيسي هو حلالته
الصحيه التي سوف تكون سلاحا ضده
كيف سوف تتغير العالم طبعا سوف يتغير في
بعض القضايا بشكل واضح من الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه
هو كان من البدايه غير مقتنع ان الحرب دي
يجب ان تقوم وقال انا مستعد حلها في 24
ساعه اذا حذفت المبالغه المرتبطه دايما
بالت فانا مقتنعا انه قادر على احداث بريك
ثرو وهتكون في اطراف كثيره راغبه في ان هي
تتعاون معاها بعد ان احرق بيض قصور
التفاهم مع الروس
لماذا تريد اقتراض لماذا تريد مصر اقتراض
ملياريورو لبناء قطار حديث وهي في نفس
الوقت التفاوض مع صندوق والله يا معتصم
انا رسول عشان اللي مش عارف مع صندوق
النقد على مبلغ
اعلى بقليل هذه المعضله لا استطيع فهمها
وانا لا استطيع فهمها هو طبعا الحكومه
بتقول انا بدات المشروعات دي بالفعل
والمشروع ده هيكون ضروري جدا الا انه يربط
الموانئ وان ده مشروع حيوي لتطوير الموانئ
والموانئ تربطها بقطار حديدي احني بيقولوا
ان ده مهم وانا معاهم ان ده مهم او ما حدش
يختلف المهم بس الحاجات المهمه كثيره فهل
في هذه الازمه اما كان من الممكن ممكن
يكون في عندهم اعتبارات انا يعني ما
اعرفهاش اما كان من الممكن تاجيل هذا
القرض والمشروع تجميد لمده عام واحد حتى
لو كانت في خسائر قليله نتفاهم مع الشركات
المتعاقدين معاه سنه واحده
فانا اشاركك هذا الاندهاش اللي ممكن
الحكومه
عندها اسباب
وقالتها ولم اسمعها
لا اعلم يعني
السلام عليكم لماذا الثوره السوريه
رضيت بتغطيه اعلاميه ودعم دولي كبير
البحرين تكتموا تكتم كبير هول هو المعيار
هل هو المعيار هو القرب من امريكا
واسرائيل ده انت ذاكرتك جيده يا حسين طبعا
ولو لاحظت ان كاميرا الجزيره غطت بشده
الثوره الصغريه لكن البحرين لا لانه
البحرين كانت مساله حساسه للسعوديه
وقالت المساله ديت مساله يعني خط احمر
وقالوا كفايه ما حدث في مصر مش عاوزين
كمان اجد انه في اضطرابات في البحرين تاتي
بتغيير في النظام وتوغل للنظام الايراني
فابتلع الامريكان وتراجع الامريكانو عن
خططهم الداعمه لما سمي بصورات الربيع
العربي وتوقفت طبعا كاميرات الجزيره خوفا
من رد الفعل السعودي ومن الفرد الفعل
الامريكي فطبعا ايوه طبعا في معيارين يعني
هو دايما في معيارين وتلاته واربعه انا
هستاذنكم في اجابه سؤالين اخرين والتوقف
ونستانف الاسبوع المقبل ان شاء الله ما هي
صحه التعديلات السعوديه لاداره بين
الاقتصاديا واضح ان كلكم بتسالوا على
تصريح لا اعلمه لغايه النهارده وانا بتابع
الاخبار مش عارف ايه هو التهديد اللي انت
سالته عليه تلاته الصدفه الغريبه ان انا
قاعد بحضر من حوالي اسبوعين على العلاقات
السعوديه الامريكيه
وفرص التطبيع مع اسرائيل يعني نفس الموضوع
اللي بتقوله عليه بس انا مش عارف ايه هو
التهديد اللي انتم بتقولوه على لسان مين
قد يكون في تصريح انا ما سمعتوش النهارده
يعني لو حد كتبهولي اكون شاكر لكن في كل
الاحوال ان شاء الله الاسبوع المقبل هيكون
عندنا حلقه عن
العلاقات السعوديه الامريكيه
والتطبيع اللي بيتكلموا عليه كثيرا هل هو
ممكن ولا لا فيما يتعلق باسرائيل
السؤال قبل الاخير هل لا تزال الشيوعيه هل
لا تزال الشيوعيه حيه في روسيا ام هذا
النموذج سقط بلا رجعه لا يوجد شيوعيه في
روسيا توجد شيوعيه في الصين هل يمكن ان
تؤدي محاكمه ترامب الى فقدانها حق الترشح
قضيه دستوريه قضائيه لا استطيع الاستاء
فيها ولكن ما اسمعه ان كل هذه القضايا
اولا لا تكفي لاقصائه
انا شاكر جدا ليكم انا اعتذر عن بعض
الاسئله التي لم افهمها واعتذر عن الاسئله
التي لم استطع الاجابه عليها وان شاء الله
ان شاء الله احنا عندنا لقاء اسبوعي تاني
الاربع المقبل فمن لم استطع الاجابه على
سؤاله اذا كنت اعرف الاجابه عليه ان شاء
الله اجيب عنه الاسبوع المقبل اشكركم
وربنا يخليكم ويسعدكم والى لقاء